THERE IS NEW CONCERNS TONIGHT
ABOUT CHINA'S MILITARY
CAPABILITIES.
THE COUNTRY RECENTLY TESTED AS
NUCLEAR CAPABLE HYPERSONIC
MISSILE.
CNN'S BRIAN TODD IS WORKING THE
STORY FOR US.
BRIAN, WHAT ARE YOU FINDING OUT?
>> WOLF, THESE EXPERTS ARE
WARNING TONIGHT ABOUT CHINA'S
NEW MISSILE CAPABILITY.
THERE IS A NEW REPORT
INDICATING CHINA COULD SOON BE
ABLE TO DEPLOY AND NUCLEAR
TIPPED MISSILE THAT U.S.
DEFENSES WOULD FIND MUCH HARDER
TO DETECT.
>> U.S. OFFICIALS TONIGHT
CLOSELY MONITORING CHINA'S
MISSILE PROGRAM, FOLLOWING A
REPORT OF A POSSIBLY ON
MINISTER MISSILE TEST.
THE FINANCIAL TIMES, CITING
UNNAMED SOURCES BRIEFED ON THE
INTELLIGENCE, REPORTS CHINA
TESTED AND NUCLEAR CAPABLE
HYPERSONIC MISSILE IN AUGUST.
THE REPORT SAYS THE MISSILE
CIRCUIT THE OF THE EARTH BEFORE
SPEEDING TOWARDS THIS TARGET,
DEMONSTRATING AND IN VANCE
CAPABILITY IN SPACE THAT "
CAUGHT U.S. INTELLIGENCE BY
SURPRISE ".
TODAY, LLOYD AUSTIN WHY NOT
COMMENTING SPECIFICALLY ON THE
FINANCIAL TIMES REPORT, SAID
THIS.
>> WE WERE CLOSELY TRYING TO
DEVELOP WHAT AND ADVANCE
CAPABILITIES AND SYSTEMS THAT
WILL ONLY INCREASE TENSIONS IN
THE REGION.
>> CHINA DENIES TESTING A
HYPERSONIC MISSILE, SAYING THE
TEST WAS A " ROUTINE SPACECRAFT
EXPERIMENT ", AND APPLYING IT
WAS FOR CIVILIAN PURPOSES.
BUT ANALYSTS SAY IF THE REPORT
IS CORRECT, CHINA'S NOT ONLY
GOT A MISSILE THAT CAN FLY IT 5
TIMES THE SPEED OF SOUND, AND
IS MORE MANOEUVRABLE THAN A
STANDARD BALLISTIC MISSILE.
>> BECAUSE THEY'RE FAST AND
THEY CAN AVOID DETECTION, THEY
CAN DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF
WARNING TIME WE HAVE, AND THE
AMOUNT OF DECISION TIME THAT
LEADERS HAVE TO RESPOND IN A
CRISIS, IF HYPERSONIC WEAPONS
ARE USED.
>> THE IDEA THAT CHINA MIGHT
HAVE FIRED A ROCKET INTO FULL
ORBIT, WITH DISMISSAL ON IT, IS
DISTURBING TO EXPERTS.
>> IF THAT'S TRUE, THEN WE NOW
HAVE TO START WORRYING ABOUT
WHETHER EVERY CHINESE SATELLITE
MIGHT NOT IN FACT BE A
DISGUISED NUCLEAR WARHEAD.
THIS IS A VERY VERY
DESTABILIZING DEVELOPMENT.
>> THE SUMMER, IT WAS REPORTED
THAT CHINA BEGAN CONSTRUCTION
OF WHAT EXPERTS SAID WERE MORE
THAN 100 NEW SILOS FOR
INTERCONTINENTAL BALLISTIC
MISSILES, AND WESTERN DESERT OF
CHINA.
>> WHAT IS VERY CLEAR IS THAT
CHINA IS PUSHING TO DEVELOP ITS
NUCLEAR CAPABILITIES, ITS
STRATEGIC INTERCONTINENTAL
COULD BE ABILITIES,
SIGNIFICANTLY BEYOND WHAT HAS
BEEN THE CASE FOR THE LAST 4
DECADES, 5 DECADES.
>> AND CHINA, ACCORDING TO U.S.
OFFICIALS, HAS BEEN MORE
AGGRESSIVE RECENTLY INGESTING
ITS WEAPONS.
>> AS OF THE END OF LAST MONTH,
SEPTEMBER OF 2021, THE PRC HAVE
LAUNCHED AT LEAST 250 BALLISTIC
MISSILES THIS YEAR.
>> BUT CHINA IS NOT ALONE IN
DEVELOPING HYPERSONIC MISSILES.
THE U.S. AND RUSSIA ARE ALSO
WORKING ON IT.
AND RECENTLY, KIM JONG-UN'S
REGIME CLAIMED NORTH KOREA JUST
FIRED A HYPERSONIC MISSILE,
WITH A WAR THAT COULD DETACH
AND GLIDE.
>> I'M CONCERNED ABOUT IS AN
UNCONSTRAINED BALLISTIC MISSILE
AND HYPERSONIC MISSILE RATES IN
EAST ASIA AND FUTURE YEARS.
WE KNOW THAT OUR MILITARY
TENSIONS BETWEEN CHINA AND
JAPAN, BETWEEN THE KOREAS,
BETWEEN THE U.S. AND CHINA.
>> EXPERTS ARE INCREASINGLY
CONCERNED ABOUT NORTH KOREA'S
HYPERSONIC MISSILE TESTS.
WHAT DID NORTH KOREA GET THE
TECHNOLOGY?
I WOULD SAY IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
WE COULD'VE GOTTEN IT FROM
CHINA, OR RUSSIA.
BUT THEY ALSO SAY CHINA AND
RUSSIA HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN
OVER NORTH KOREA HAVING THAT
CAPABILITY.
SO IT IS